[Music]
Texans are very proud of how tough their
state is in fact and I mention this
before I hearing the phrase don't mess
with Texas well that sounded like a dare
to me I think it's time we found out
just how tough Texas is that's right
ladies and gentlemen let's mess with
Texas
[Applause]
2068 208,000 poverty with square miles
please welcome the state of Texas
[Applause]
here
here comes Alaska the head take up Texas
the tundra
[Music]
[Applause]
he snuck up on Texas that was low Hawaii
in the place a tough time for Texas
it's picking up Hawaii
Laska
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here comes water
and Florida's completely high on bath
salts
he wants to eat Texas his face
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we'll be right back